in triangle ABC let a b equal root 23 BC  equal 3 and C a equal four then the  value of the cotangent of angle a plus  the cotangent of angle C all over the  cotangent of angle B is equal to what  to solve this problem we will use the  law of cosines to solve for the cosine  of angle C divide both sides of this  equation by the sine of angle C to get  the cotangent of angle C is equal to a  squared plus b squared minus c squared  all over 4 times the area of the  triangle we can derive similar formula  for the cotangent of angle a and the  cotangent of angle B we are given the  side lengths in this problem and we need  to calculate this ratio so we substitute  in the formulas we've derived then we  will simplify 4 times the area of the  triangle cancels out then we just need  to simplify this fraction and we end up  with two B squared all over a squared  plus c squared minus B squared after  some simplification we get that this is  equal to 2 and that's the answer